So to give you, again,
still a little bit of intuition, but
getting a little more formal, so here we
have the same person walking at Time t,
and then there's a question of
what do we do at Time t plus 1.
The idea is that from Time t,
we have some prediction or
some belief that's indicated here in
red of where we think the person is.
Okay, and that's our prior.
So, before we take any measurements
at Time t plus 1, this is our belief.
By the way, I will go back and forth,
the slides sometimes go back and
forth, between whether we're talking
about moving between t minus 1 and
t, or t and t plus 1.
It doesn't matter.
It's just going from one step to the
next and sometimes I screw up one way,
sometimes I screw up another way.
This is like the story of my life.
All right, so at red, we have the idea
is we have some prediction to Time t and
we want to know what's
happening at t plus 1.
At Time t plus 1, we take a measurement.
That's what's shown here in green.
Okay, so we had some distribution that
was our belief about what's there and
now we have some measurement.
Now notice, that this measurement
is also a distribution.
We're going to talk in a little
bit about what that means
it means two different things.
One, you can think of is that,
given that the person is someplace,
how likely would be the current
measurement that I got?
So you see here, let's assume
the measurement was there, okay?
This distribution says, not how likely
is the person at a particular place,
that's what I'm trying to estimate.
What this distribution says is,
how likely would this measurement be,
how likely would I be to get
this measurement if the person
was at these different locations?
That's a little confusing.
When we do the math of likelihood,
that'll become clearer.
For now, you can think of a measurement
that's just a little bit noisy,
I don't know, you know, it gives me some
bounds on where the person probably is.
And then finally taking that prior be,
belief or
prediction and the measurement,
I come with what's referred to as either
a corrected prediction final estimate.
Or the technical term is the posterior
distribution is to where I think it is,
and that's what's shown in blue.
So I go from a prior, or an old belief,
to a measurement, to a new belief